.
>> WHEN I GET IN THERE, YOU'RE
IN FOR A WORLD OF PAIN.
>> Sean: A WORLD OF PAIN.
THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW IS
SENATOR TOM COTTON.
AUTHOR OF AN UPCOMING BOOK.
SENATOR, WE HAVE JUST OVER
400 MILLION BARRELS LEFT IN THE
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE, THE
ADMINISTRATION TODAY MADE IT
CLEAR THEY HAVE NO PLANS OF
STOPPING THEIR RELEASE OF MORE
OIL.
EXPLAIN WHY THIS IS SO
DANGEROUS.
>> [LAUGHS]
IT'S OBVIOUS WHY THEY ARE DOING
THAT.
THEY HAVE AN ELECTION IN 34 DAYS
IN THE PRICE OF GAS IS GONE UP
BY A QUARTER IN MOST PLACES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
I THINK YOU PUT IT WELL.
AND AS I WRITE, DEMOCRATS PLAN
IS DECLINED BY DESIGN.
WE DON'T HAVE $5 A GALLON GAS IN
THIS COUNTRY BY ACCIDENT.
IT'S NOT AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE.
IT'S NOT BAD LUCK OR THE EVIL
MACHINATIONS OF OIL COMPANY
EXECUTIVES OR OPEC.
IT'S BECAUSE JOE BIDEN AND
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS WANT GAS
TO BE THAT EXPENSIVE.
THEY WANT YOU TO GET OUT OF YOUR
GAS GUZZLING SUV OR MINIVAN.
THEY WANT FARMERS TO HAVE TO
STOP USING DIESEL FOR TRACTORS
AND OTHER FIRM INSTRUMENTS.
THEY THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO REPLACE THINGS THINGS
WITH ELECTRIC VEHICLES WHICH BY
THE WAY REALLY ARE COAL POWERED
OR NATURAL GAS POWERED OR
NUCLEAR POWERED BECAUSE THE
ELECTRICITY HAS TO COME FROM
SOMEWHERE.
IT DOESN'T COME FROM THE SUN
WHEN IT'S NOT SHINING OR THE
WIND WHEN IT'S NOT BLOWING.
THIS GET BACK TO THE FAR LESS
ANTICAPITALIST VIEWS.
ENERGY LITERALLY POWERS OUR
MODERN ECONOMY.
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS DIDN'T HAVE
A MUCH DIFFERENT QUALITY OF LIFE
IN JESUS' DISCIPLES AND THAT'S
BECAUSE SOURCES OF ENERGY WERE
THE SAME.
IT'S ONLY IN THE LAST 200 YEARS.
FOSSIL FUELS, COAL AND OIL AND
GAS AND NUCLEAR POWER THAT WE'VE
ACHIEVED TRUE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
>> Laura: SENATOR.
YEAH.
LET ME JUMP IN.
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW WHAT NEXT SO
LET'S SAY YOU DO MANAGE TO GET
THE SEAT AND YOU TAKE THE
MAJORITY.
MAYBE YOU TAKE A COUPLE SEATS.
WHAT CAN REPUBLICANS DO TO STOP
THIS MADNESS IF ANYTHING?
>> AT A MINIMUM WE CAN USE OUR
SPENDING POWER WHICH WE'VE GOT
TO DO EVERY YEAR, FORCED THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE
CERTAIN ACTIONS WHETHER IT'S
PERMITTING NEW PIPELINES OR
OTHER OIL AND GAS DEVELOPMENTS,
ISSUING NEW PERMITS.
WE DID THIS.
WE WON THE SENATE AND HOUSE IN
2015.
WE LIFTED A 40-YEAR-OLD BAN ON
OIL EXPORTS GOING BACK TO THE
JIMMY CARTER ERA.
THESE ARE THINGS, STEPS WE CAN
TAKE TO RESTORE AMERICA'S OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION.
WE CAN ENCOURAGE MORE DRILLING,
MORE PRODUCTION NOT ONLY FOR OUR
OWN ENERGY NEEDS BUT FOR OUR
ALLIES AND PARTNERS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING THIS ON
PURPOSE.
THEY RECOGNIZE THE POLITICAL
DANGER OF IT.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE TAKING SUCH
RISKY STEPS.
>> Laura: IT'S BEYOND OBVIOUS
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DOING WHICH
BRINGS ME TO MY NEXT QUESTION.
AGAIN, IF THE REPUBLICANS TAKE
THE MAJORITY, CAN WE EXPECT
HEARINGS IN THE SENATE THAT
PROBE WHETHER THE MOTIVATION FOR
RELEASING MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF BARRELS AND POTENTIALLY
ENDANGERING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
IN A TIME OF EMERGENCY, WHEN
THAT WAS DONE FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
WHO WAS INVOLVED IN THAT
DECISION-MAKING.
TO ME THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S NECESSARILY
AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE BUT
PRETTY DAMN IMPORTANT THAT WE
FIND OUT WHY THAT WAS DONE.
>> WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT.
I THINK WE KNOW ARE GOING TO
FIND OUT IN THE END.
IT'S THE POLITICAL CZARS
THROUGHOUT THE ADMINISTRATION
REPORT IT BACK TO THE PRESIDENT.
LOCAL ALLIES, POLITICAL AIDES IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Laura: THAT CAN'T BE
ALLOWED.
>> IT'S NOT THE POLITICAL
PETROLEUM RESERVE.
THEY RECOGNIZE EVEN THOUGH THEY
WANT TO GAS TO BE A $5 A GALLON,
THEY RECOGNIZE THIS IS A UNIQUE
PAIN POINT FOR MOST AMERICAN
FAMILIES AND THEY GET TO AT
LEAST APPEAR TO BE TAKING ACTION
34 DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THEY ARE BLAMING OPEC AND EVIL
OIL COMPANIES FOR TRYING TO
DRIVE UP THE PRICE OF OIL BUT
THAT DIRECTLY TRANSLATES BACK TO
THEIR OWN FAILED ENERGY
POLICIES.
LIKE HURRICANE IAN.
IMAGINE IF WE HAD A HURRICANE
>> Laura: THEY ARE DEFRAUDING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT'S NOT THEY ARE OIL.
IT'S OUR OIL AND THEY ARE
PLAYING POLITICS UNTIL THAT
ISSUE.
I DON'T THINK WE CAN ASSUME
ANYTHING.
IT HAS TO BE PROVEN THAT THIS
WAS A CALCULATED POLITICAL MOVE
WHICH IS ENDANGERING THE FUTURE
OF AMERICA AND I WANT TO KNOW
WHO WAS RESPONSIBLE AND I WANT
TO SEE THE EMAILS.
I THINK YOU ARE PERFECTLY
POSITIONED IF YOU GET THE SENATE
TO TAKE CHARGE.
WE CAN'T LET THIS HAPP